josé bové vous ne serez pas étonnés
quand vous fasse une interview fromage
ou dessert
[Musique]
attention josé bové est ce que vous
préféreriez un week-end dans le loft ou
en prison en prison il va pas réfléchi
non adéquation
pourquoi parce que le loft ça me fait
gerber ah oui complète plus que la
prison encore encore plus leur plaisir
parce que même en prison j'ai même pas
regardé est ce que vous préférez aller
manger chez mcdo ou en prison
je préfère je n'ai est-ce que préférer
les belles voitures ou les beaux
tracteurs g ni l'un ni l'autre
donc je fais avec préféré quand vous
coupe la moustache ou la parole ça ne me
gêne pas qu'on me coupe la parole
1 je suis habitué vous préférez la
prison pour les enfants de 13 ans ou la
liberté pour les présidents de 69 ans je
pense que ce que je préfère c'est
l'abolition de la prison pour tout le
monde mais on fera comment je pense
qu'on n'a pas besoin de prison il ya
d'autres méthodes pour faire en sorte de
réparer parce que la prison ne répare
absolument pas les délits la prison parc
des gens pour un certain temps et puis
après un meurtre en fait quoi
je pense qu'il ya d'autres systèmes que
la prison la prison aujourd'hui c'est
n'est pas simplement un enfermement une
privation de liberté c'est la négation
de la personne et je crois que donc par
rapport à ça il faut changer
radicalement 16 modes d'enfermement vous
préférez la coiffure de luc ferry ou son
projet pour l'éducation nationale je le
préfère de dos vous préférez que les
ministres soient augmenté de 70 % qu'ils
prennent directement à la caisse je
préfèrerais qu'on augmente le smic
j'ai fait un petit peu un monte le smic
combien je peux combien 15%
20h25 non non non 2 de 2,2 non pas 2 1 6
2 pour ces deux courses à ce qui c'était
une tradition et c'est tout moi je
trouve ça vraiment
scandaleux que un mec qui bosse je veux
dire un truc terrible
un mec qui veut de deux tiers des
travailleurs qui gagnent donc un smic
qui tourne autour de 600 enfants un peu
près et et qu' on est très bien organisé
en matière de protection sociale pour
quelqu'un qui n'a plus de travail avec
les apl les machins moi je le sais parce
que je m'en occupe
et je suis toujours un petit peu choqué
de voir qu'il ya à peine mille francs de
différence entre un mec protéger
normalement un gars qui a des papiers je
parle 1 et qui a une apl et qu'un machin
il ya presque il ya presque 1000 ou 1500
mal de différences entre un mec qui
grattent et un gars kinky à ses papiers
et qui est en fin de droits et moi je
trouve que moi si j'avais été au
gouvernement
j'aurais fait ce qui a été fait un jour
c'est d'augmenter de 30% le smic tout le
monde avait crié au scandale dit ça
marchera pas et tout mais je crois que
ça résoudrait pas mal de problèmes
si on mettait le carrément si on
augmente explique de 30% serait à dire
que entre quelqu'un qui travaille
quelqu'un qui travaille pas qui est une
réelle différence puisque la protection
et je dis que ça serait ça serait bien
faisons le de 30% d'accor tout le monde
est d'accord
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus